à l'annoncé des résultats pour l'équipe
de marie claude jarrot c'est le
soulagement
marie claude jarrot 1954 voir soit 46,57
% c'est pourtant ce que des mandats est
loin d'être gagnée pour la main forte à
marie claude jarrot ne l'emportent sur
le fut avec 126 points d'avance c'était
une bataille difficile parce que tout
les forces les plus hétéroclites se sont
coalisés contre contre nous contre nous
qui avions un projet de territoire
nous avons aussi un bilan très positif
comme certains en pensent très positifs
et les mots célia viennent de nous
viennent de nous donner l'autorisation
de poursuivre notre projet il y avait
pourtant cru mais la coalition de gauche
n'a pas réussi à renverser la table son
électorat ne s'est pas suffisamment
mobilisé
c'est effectivement une déception a même
si encore une fois il ya quelques mois
en arrière on ne donnait battus
et largement on a réussi à mettre en
difficulté la maire sortante qui ne
réalisent pas ce soir un score
exceptionnel a aujourd'hui malgré tout
on garde ça le combat n'est pas terminé
mais aussi ce soir c'est une défaite
pour nous mais le combat continue
politiquement en troisième place avec un
peu moins de 10% des suffrages
lilian noirot fait mieux qu'en 2014 mais
le candidat de debout la france peine
encore à convaincre de nouveaux
électeurs
nous allons continuer en tout cas de
mener nos actions terrain d'aller à la
rencontre des monts suresnes et des
montcelliens pendant ces six ans de
continuer à être une opposition
intelligente en défendant les projets
lorsqu'ils vont dans le sens de
l'intérêt général et nous opposer
lorsque pour nous il ya des dérives ce
soir marie claude jarrot a sauvé son
siège à la mairie des moins certains
pronostics montceau-les-mines reste à
droite
[Applaudissements]